[Music]
kevin and i just decided that we were
going to take a year and write something
that we really really wanted to see an
original idea something that felt fun
and he said i have a kernel of an idea
nick cage playing nic cage and i was
like yes absolutely 100 let's do it we
didn't know nicholas cage at the time we
had never met him one of our friends
said like this is one of the worst
career decisions you guys could have
made there was no guarantee that it
would get made we got another offer just
came in this morning excellent what's it
about i was hearing rumblings about it
it just kept coming to me and i i said i
have no interest in playing myself in a
movie it's just not something i'd want
to do
well then i got a letter
tom wrote him a letter that really laid
out in a thoughtful way why we wanted to
do the project and reiterated that it
was truly a fan letter basic because we
loved him and we wanted to celebrate him
it was the kind of
letter that i could tell
had genuine enthusiasm in it and it
looked like
someone that actually had some knowledge
about my filmography and then i read the
script and i thought he's really taking
us on an adventure that is quite
exciting there was no movie without
nicholas cage being on board that is for
sure
i'll take it